Gael série est une fleuriste passionnée
sa spécialité la fleur française de
saison mais avant de se lancer dans
cette aventure voici trois ans elle a
connu plusieurs vies professionnelles
sportif de haut niveau durant 15 ans
elle participe à de nombreuses
compétitions de danse sur glace elle se
reconvertit ensuite dans l'immobilier
puis la communication elle y enchaîne
les expériences professionnelles sans
s'y sentir épanouis c'est vrai que quand
on a fait du sport pendant très
longtemps comme ça on se pose jamais
vraiment la question de ce qu'on va
faire après donc ça avait pas été
vraiment anticipé et du coup j'ai
on va dire que je j'ai expérimenté
l'emploi par le faire en 2020 le
confinement gèle son projet d'embauche
au sein d'un cabinet de recrutement avec
la volonté de se reconnecter à la nature
elle vend les fleurs d'un de ses amis
producteurs de roses c'est le point de
départ de sa future entreprise mais
aussi de son flower truck qu'elle
installe à Guyancourt
ça s'est fait au fur et à mesure en fait
et c'est j'ai commencé tout petit avec
juste une planche avec deux petites
tréteaux et puis j'avais pas envie de me
lancer tout de suite dans les dans la
boutique parce que ça
c'est des charges je savais pas trop par
où passer donc on regarde sur internet
j'ai trouvé une remorque voilà pour
pouvoir me protéger un commerce atypique
qui attire de nombreux clients
et je suis toujours agréablement surpris
en très bonne fleur c'est pas très cher
et c'est vrai que c'est diversifié et
les fleurs tiennent vraiment longtemps
ça tient au moins 15 jours facile sans
problème le concept plait alors en 2021
elle ouvre une deuxième adresse à
Versailles et embauche une salariée la
plupart des entrepreneurs pourraient le
dire enfin si on est livré à soi-même
donc en fait les les réussites on les a
pour nous puis les défaites on les a
pour nous aussi c'est l'apprentissage
voilà je pense pas qu'on puisse naître
entrepreneur on le devient et on le
devient de mieux en mieux au fur et à
mesure avec son entreprise florissante
et ses clients fidèles Gaëlle a enfin
trouvé son épanouissement professionnel